here as well started the simplest
building blocks of faith and that would
be the white to red the blacks you of
course we kept a glove that in itself is
a chronic wound or the sound tone of the
game implies that everything we do needs
to be elegant minimalistic and it has to
have a certain attitude where we use
colors the accents are very specific and
controlled that's where the attitude
comes from her body needs to reflect her
life what she does who she is faiths
physicality and and freedom of movement
it's interesting in contrast to a very
calm form of society faith and the
runners stay to sort of step outside of
this world voluntarily I admire her
independence or integrity her daredevil
ways she's a runner she's very strong
the overall look should give them a
sense that well you shouldn't mess
around with faith
message is game that's focused very
heavily on movement we've had parkour
artists coming talk to us they can teach
us a lot about the moves that we have in
the game and how we can also expand on
it we're building on the first message
when it comes to the move sense that
faith has everything is geared towards
traversing navigating this environment
we want the player to be able to
experiment and find different paths in
the environment you know that you can
get there but how and that's when you
explore you know not just the
environment but also what is it that
faith can do so for the skill player
they might find the quickest the fastest
the most rewarding path for them
somebody with less skill might find a
safer longer route it's important for us
that everybody who wants to play the
game can play the game and not only are
we building a broad moveset we're also
building combats with the moveset in
mind he would analyze the geometry in a
combat encounter to see how you can use
that against the enemies won't talk
about combat we are selecting very
special sounds for that we're having
very tight controlled hits they kind of
speak about faith power and efficiency
because she is a projectile I know she
does hit she hits quick fast and hard
and then moves on
we are redefining the role of the
runners to allow for more varied
gameplay for more varied experience we
will expand on who she is in this world
of why she doing what she's doing
what's her reason for being faithful
this is a girl actually tattoo the eye
you're doing for reason is to make a
point we are creating faith for a new
generation